هل معنى ذلك بان هناك في داخل الجيش من
يرفض هذا الانقلاب هذا الانقلاب ما كان
متوقع ان اطلاقا ولا يمكنك اي ظروف معينه
اذا كانت تقتضي تدخل من قبل الجيش
لانه كما تعلمون لم يكن هناك
اي ازمه اجتماعيه ولم تكن هناك اي ازمه
اقتصاديه من الدول التي حققت اكبر التقدم
ممكن على الصعيد الاقتصادي
بنسبه نموه
11.9% في عام 2022
ونسبه نمو
تقدم بسبعه بالمئه للسنه 2023
وهناك زياده في النمو الاقتصادي ب
الحكم الرشيد والديمقراطي الذي جرت تصديقه
من قبل كل دول الاعضاء مجبر على التدخل
ولحد الان لم نحصل على ردين ايجابي على
الطلب قدمته اليك واس اي تدخل عسكري في
النيجر هل هو محسوب العواقب
مشكله ذلك لكل المنطقه ولكن الامر كله
سيعتمد على طبيعه التدخل هذا وبهذا الصدد
نحن نستطيع ان نثق
بالخبراء العسكريين ضمن مجموعه الاكواس لو
انه لم يحصل تدخل
عسكري فان ذلك سيكون مسار للمنطقه اذا
تركزت نجح هذا الانقلاب كما تعلمون حصلت
ثلاثه انقلابات في غرب افريقيا وهذا سيكون
الرابع واذا ما نجح هذا الانقلاب الرابع
فهذا فتاكدوا انه ستكون قلابات اخرى
مستقبلا والمجموعات الارهابيه ستجد وسائل
واسفل للتور قدما نحو الجنوب هل انتم
مطلعون على هذه الخطه هنا اعلي خطه التدخل
العسكري طبعا في حال عدم التجاوب
لا استطيع ان اعرف ما الذي توصل اليه منخط
لان هذا كان اجتماع
كان وكان اجتماعا مغلقا ما اعرفه انهم
اعلنوا بانهم قد وضعوا مفهومه مثل العمليه
العسكريه وقد حددوا تعجنهم تسهيلات والامر
على رؤساء الدول اذا اذا ما تقرر وقرروا
ان هذا التدقيق العسكري لا مفر منه
الضروري هل لديكم معلومات او مؤشرات تقول
بانه ربما يكون هناك جديد على الصعيد
السياسي مستمره عن طريق قنوات اخرى وخاصه
عن اتصالات الهاتفيه وبالتالي للمناقشات
ما زالت جاريه والحوار لم يبقى تماما مع
مجموعه
حاليا تجري مناقشات
مع فرنسا ومع دول اخرى التقيت
الفرنسيه والتي اكدت لدعمها للحكومه
الشرعيه في النيجر وان فرنسا تؤيد عوده
الرئيس بازون الى الى منصبه الرئاسي
وفرنسا تؤيد عوده واستعاده كل المؤسسات
التي يتظاهر الانبيون
[موسيقى]